hey everyone it's my photos and welcome
today's presentation on the bottles SNR
levels for Tuesday November 7 2017 now
you know I posted the first video up
yesterday showing the markets analysis
from Sunday night into Monday morning
and I'm going to recap some of what
unfolded right after I recorded that
video it's quite interesting and what
happened again I got some comments you
know people want to see it on other
markets I'm going to talk about crude
and Dax as well as well as E minis and
gold and euro currency but again you
know I'm doing a webinar on the 8th on
Wednesday if you haven't signed up I
suggest you sign up the link is in the
description you know if you can't attend
it's at 10:00 a.m. I understand you know
not everyone can attend you know people
got to work but in kids to school
whatever then at least if you're
registered you know you could be on the
list for the distribution that should
come from investor inspiration to watch
the replay so a brief disclaimer before
I begin this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any other type of investment
decision future train contains essential
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for training anyway those
were sufficient risk capital should
consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results the tools I
use in this presentation are the Balthus
snr levels which is a new indicator
right it it uses order flow to define
support and resistance levels as the
market is trading and the order flows
trader which is the volume footprint
chart now again the SNR levels will work
on a normal bar chart so if you got
nothing right now if you have no ninja
trader no order flows trader that's fine
you can go you can download the free
version of ninja trader and run the
bottles SNR levels on the free version
you just need a data feed you can get a
you know your broker can provide you
with a data feed and that hopefully for
minimal amounts so anyway let's take a
look at the markets real quick alright
so the first market I'll talk about is
gold right now it's about to whisper on
three in the morning Chicago time and
again I've been preparing for this
presentation that's why I'm looking
the markets now but let's just walk it
back a little bit here there so if you
remember yesterday I forgot what time I
recorded the presentation yesterday I
think it was around 2:00 a.m. you know
you remember I remember talking about
this this level here on Monday night
which is a straight day Tuesday you know
this support level right it broke down
through there this support was what
twelve eighty and a half more or less
twelve eighty point six you'll notice
how if you were to scrunch this chart up
okay again you know I I've experimented
with drawing out these things a hundred
bars or whatever I mean you could adjust
it however you like once you have it too
many bars out it does get a bit your
charts can get a bit cluttered if there
were a bunch of indicators at nine if
there was a bunch of signals on there
but again you know if you know the
basics about support and resistance
right when support breaks down it
becomes resistance okay and if you're
gonna treat that if you believe in that
right and you know there's a lot of
truth to it look for signals you know
look for shorts if it's going to be a
resistance area you know and you're
testing it and you get a signal to get
short it can be a legitimate signal is
it's a legitimate you know the markets
telling you hey get short right if your
support breaks down and it's gonna be
recovery systems if we trade back up
there I hear who trade it back up here I
mean if you you tried getting shortened
here yeah maybe you got stopped out if
you got a stop right on the other side
but again you know if you're using this
as a resistance you know you might want
to get short a little bit ahead of it or
you know inside of it or you know I
don't say on the other side but
definitely inside of it you know we
didn't come back up here but now you're
getting a signal you know you have this
resistance level here right you know
this what kills me why some traders is
they try to be so precise so exact in
their trading like oh no it has to come
right up inside this level for me to get
short well it doesn't have to if you're
getting a signal here right ahead of the
resistance from earlier your support
becoming a resistance you getting a
resistance signal here you take the
resistance signal you get short in here
right even if you're you know okay so
forget this blue you know forget this
support that became resistant say you're
trading this we move this here say
you're just trading this right look at
it we sold off came right back up to
that area and then you had a nice
sell-off you know from the 12 12 80 area
where we sell down to we sold down to 12
seven new below it was 12 77 post 78
even down here you're getting another
signal saying hey there's resistance
selling in here there's someone's got
their foot on this market you know
pushing it down then what happens is we
trade down into new low seventy six
right then we just sort of hang around
here going into the day session you got
this by here we did come back in test
that area I mean we got through it by
what what was that level so the zone you
know seventy seven point four down to
seventy seven point one would we trade
down sixty nine seventy six point nine
so two ticks on the other side you know
if you you know if you're strict on it
and you have a stop right here you know
right on the other side at seventy seven
you get stopped out you know seventy six
point nine you're gonna get stopped out
you know if you're a little bit lenient
and you know willing to give it a little
breathing room maybe you're not stopped
out again it depends on where you're
gonna place your stop you know it sucks
that you know the market comes down here
just pokes through and then makes that
rally that you're looking for just as
you know here on this other side right
you got this this trade and you know he
started to sell off then you rally back
up again you got one tick through
seventy nine point two is the top of
this red zone we hit seventy nine point
three sold off a little bit but then the
buying came back in and you know so you
know if you're not stopped out here they
say you have a year stop up here at
seventy nine point four point five then
you're stopped out mark goes up then
again you know almost at that same level
I mean it is the same level you get that
sign that hey there is selling pressure
coming in here you can see it in the
order flow if I had an order flow chart
up but you know this indicator is
designed to run on a normal bar chart so
it's actually reading it's actually
doing the order flow analysis in the
background imagine having an order flow
footprint chart running in the
background and just putting up the signs
on a bond a bar charge basically what's
going on and again you know if you're
getting choices a one-minute chart so
you got time you know you got time this
whole bar is one minute here this next
bar you know even if you're the slowest
trader you got mitten
on your gloves on sure you got trade
with your feet you could surely within a
minute you know get short in somewhere
in this bar you know at you know it's
called 1278 say he's going into the next
bar so you're gonna move a violent move
from 78 you know right down to 75 point
you know we make a new low in the next
three minutes sort of bounce around boom
78 you know up here only 270 you oh is
that seventy two point three bond sup
here you another sell signal this one
yeah it didn't work out yeah what
stopped you out there's there's no I'm
not gonna say oh you got to place your
stop way up here and no yeah I'd be
placing it you know two or three ticks
past this the zones I would been stopped
out and then it makes the move you know
what can you do such as life here this
one never worked out then here this one
you know what happens get a nice trade
back up in here into the zone you know
seventy six point six you just trade all
the way down to seven you know more or
less 75 in here you know you're coming
into the noon time so you know there's
there to host again you know people say
oh you know I had a loss here or had a
loss here well [__] it I mean you're
making it back on this one next trade
here you know even if you miss this
trade you missed this trade from 78 down
to 73 five bucks in the in the in the
gold you know you still getting you know
some decent trading opportunities I'm
not every trade is gonna be a winner you
know I don't give [__] what you're
trading you know you know I honestly I
wish you know I got a guy I have a
friend in Hong Kong he's a he's a great
trading mind you know i I've sat down
with them I've met him in person and you
know we've talked about the markets what
what we think works what doesn't work
and you know at the end of the day yeah
he's also in a quest for for something
that's got a high percentage winners you
know what he wants to do it's just you
know I'll just throw a hundred contracts
you know if we find something in the
minis that works I'll throw a hundred
contracts at it you know if it's if it's
consistent and you know go from there
now again you know if you're not a big
believer and support becomes resistance
so this was that buy from earlier right
get this out here again you know you
draw out these zones however you want I
don't like to draw it out too far
otherwise
it gets a little bit messy and on the
charts I mean you know use your eyes you
know I know everyone likes to have
everything
computerized but again look at this
support becomes resistance you break
down you break down through it what do
you do you trade back up in here
you if you were to draw it out I mean
look at this I can't extend that but
I'll just draw it out here again where
you know where is your resistance right
you're trading below this area now again
right you have a big sell-off right this
is 77 we'll call it 77 and a half you're
trading down to two and a half you come
back up you think it's going to stop
right on a dime there's so much buying
going on in here then it overshoots it
by three four ticks and then your
resistance level comes in again and you
sell off you know there are guys I know
traders you know this is how they trade
support becomes resistance resistance
become support and they're just sitting
here loading up orders who would break
down okay I know I got this level here
and I'm alone at risk three ticks if I
get three bucks out of it you know I'm
gonna whisk four ticks I get four bucks
out of it notice three or four tea you
know 30 or 40 cents to get four dollars
you know that they'll take that trade
any time so let's take a look at another
market here okay so this is crudo this
is a one-minute chart okay and they have
people that know me know I prefer to
trade on range based charts but I know a
lot of people like like minute a chart
so that's why I'm focusing now on minute
phase charts and again you know one of
the things you got deal with when you're
dealing with minute page charts is
you're gonna have some bars that are
very small like this one's got to price
levels here and here whereas the next
bar after it's got one two three four
five six seven price levels and I say
you got to deal with that in your
analysis you got to understand you know
especially if you're looking at order
flow you got to understand you know the
importance of these smaller bars and the
bigger bars so you know let's just take
it back from about 6:00 in the morning
yesterday except my charts unscrew chart
I think I think it was about 5:30 but
anyway you know so six they're you
getting you know by signal here you got
another buy signal here's around the 57
24 area do you get a rally mean that
much 10 cents up to 30 34 sort of come
back down into that area or do your
trade you know where you have this zone
right where he had the buying coming in
earlier that you knew you had some
supportive buying coming in here in this
bar in this bar and look what happens we
sort of we want to call us a term to use
for that you sort of drift back down
into this area down in here around the
24 area the only where between 20 to 24
you should be buying you got two zones
two areas here doing stacked on top of
each other so you know there's buying in
this sort of in this I don't say pocket
but in this you know this little area
right here so you know if you're able to
buy it in there 24 I mean look whatever
we do we come back down back down to 22
draw this out it's right here I mean you
know we look at that you trade down here
to 22 right it's still within these
zones said if you were to extend them
out then you know you would see that
then boom then the move happens what do
you do is shoot up we shoot up to 48
it's a nice move you know it's a you
know 20 cent move in the crude before
you know by 7:00 o'clock
Chicago time so anyway we just start
drifting around drifting around news
makes the chart a little smaller it's a
little easier to see again you get some
selling pressure coming in here you do
pop up it right on 8 o'clock
you don't one get four cents five cents
through it you know before it short
before it starts selling off again you
know we got the buying in here just sort
of go sideways again it's a minute based
chart now you started breaking down okay
and again you know it's a minute based
charge so you're getting along in here
at 8:15 you know you're looking at 8:30
and it's still a train around breakeven
you you know 30 minutes later 15 minutes
later you might want to consider you
know you're not getting paid on the
trade I want to consider getting out so
then you know so you got your zones here
right support becomes resistance
resistant these come support draw these
zones out a little bit so you could
understand how to trade support and
resistance I mean it's you know I'm not
claiming to invent that saying you know
support becomes resistance resistant you
know that's been around for 400
I mean you'll read the classic textbooks
on technical analysis Edwards and McGee
explains it all so it's not like I'm
just making this up to fit the narrative
no it'sit's it's how people trade it's
all very successful traders have been
trading for many years
here's your support here area this blue
area right earlier you had the support
trade down support becomes resistance
now you're getting resistant selling up
in here here here
you know what level is this 57 1257 15
you know 14 in here so I mean if you
could be selling in this bar already you
know that that's great you know selling
at 57 15 trains all the way down below
50 650 700 gets down to 56 once at a t56
93 is is the low at that time you know
you do test it you rally back up here
then you get some buying good buy and
sell here and the sell breaks down stops
you out or over here then 10 o'clock 10
o'clock things got a little bit messy no
other way to describe it but you could
see here at 9:58 you had this a little
bit here you had this buy here but it
ran right into a cell you know it's been
nicer if you didn't have that cell in
there but again you know you're dealing
with one minute charge sometimes it's
gonna get a little hairy in the sense
that you know if you got small bars you
might get some signals on there and
there's nothing you can do about it if
the mall and bar is small but as you can
see right you take this trade okay then
you you know it tells you to get out get
out use maybe to scratch the trade
you're short you get stopped out okay
you know maybe those you know between
the two you lose a tick or two ticks
okay fine fair enough you know you just
had two trades one winner one loser
you're down two ticks fine whatever then
boom you get another signal here it's a
minute base chart so you can get in you
know as soon as this bar is about to
close and if you got in on you know Don
this bar here what's this price we're
trading 57:20 you call it 57:18 in here
boom big selling immediately trades down
to 10
you know that's quick 10 ticks in the
crude you know it's a hundred bucks so
say you get short say you're short here
hold it okay boom-boom-boom zoo training
around breakeven you know that's ten ten
ten twenty you starting to tick down
again 57 ten okay look it's going down
back down to 57 you know oh three or
four then it just sort of hangs around
here sideways here we're trading 50s you
know just still below that 57:20 area in
here we have this cell which is what
this one here 57:22 now this is 57 22
you're still below that resistance area
and you're getting some more sell and
selling pressure coming in 57 16 57 18
and we trade what do we do it we trade
back down 202 again you know so you get
you know you're you're able to catch
these little these little moves you know
like this one yeah you just sort of spin
your wheels for five minutes but then
you know boom you get another signal
it's giving you another opportunity to
get short in there okay then later in
the day time is it here there's my clock
here so it's 12 you know whatever twelve
12:03 and you got a sell signal here or
where am I here 1203 and look at this
it's right at the opening price and
though you know this line here is if you
go to ninja trader you go indicators
they got a nice indicator which I like
to use cuz you know you gotta have some
sort of date time frame reference and
it's it's this one current day open high
low close yeah free boom some people are
selling this for 150 bucks but it's free
you usually add it you could change
whatever colors a high is you see the
green lines on my chart the low is the
red line and the open is suppose this
orange actually looks a bit more yellow
but anyway you know on a market that's
directionless you tend to hang around
the opening price alright even though
you know the markets got big fluctuation
above and below if we start hanging
around you know at some point start
hanging around the opening price at that
point the market you know it's sort of
found its value and just sort of
rotating around value and you're gonna
move above it you're gonna move below it
and you know it's gonna give you some
trading opportunities you know even
though it's kind of a boring market but
if you understand support and resistance
it's gonna give you some nice trading
opportunities
so here you go right at that level okay
it's giving yourself signals telling you
there's some support resistance selling
here and what is this 57 you know 27 is
that level but say you're getting short
you know in the next bar - you know
57:24 in 57 22 down in here this is 22
here you know say you're late alright
say you're eating your your your roast
beef sandwich and by the time you press
sell its you know it's trading down here
57 22 okay fine you know you're short at
22 just sort of hangs your officers
because you know it's lunchtime it's
gone
something making monster moves you know
very quick but it's sort of wine you
know down next thing you know we're
trained 5714 then just sort of hang it
around we're still and you're still in
the money a little bit a few cents you
know still in the money still in the
money still in the money not really
moving anywhere again you know you're on
a 1-minute chart
honestly if I was short at 20 at 12:03
and you know if I'm looking at it here
at 12:30 and I'm one of my five cents
six seven cents in the money I just take
it I'm not gonna look for a move I'd be
bored already you know expecting the
move to happen it hasn't really happened
but you know the markets quiet I mean
look at this some of these bars got to
price levels is basically bid and offers
training basically bid and offer trading
that's it that's it that's how quiet it
is but anyway you know if you want those
people and all you don't want to you
know stick with the sinking ship don't
wait for it to either stop me out or go
to a big profit target you know 57 you
know the opening price 27 right here
right and telling you get short around
22 24 actually trains all the way back
down to 5700 all right before it snaps
back then you're gonna buy signal here
at 1:20 in the afternoon and you know
what is this where we're trading 5710
and when we do 57 you can call 57 10 you
know this is 10 right here
you know this bar is you know anyone
call 12 you know that's the high of this
bar is 12 the next you know two or three
minutes we don't even get above 12 so we
say you're filled at 12 you know in the
old days when you call the floor you'd
be filled at 12 no matter what but you
say you filled in 12 what happens look
over the next you know 15 minutes what
we do we trade all the way back up to 2
unchanged which is unchanged with the
opening price which is 57:27 that's 15
eventually we do get a little bit on the
other side of it but you know by this
time it's already getting late in the
afternoon it's 2:30
you know I preferred you know crude for
me basically after 2:10 in the afternoon
which the old floor closed it really
gets thin but you know in some days you
do get some numbers coming out you know
after late in the afternoon here yeah
that's why you see this volatility also
you got the markers as well and you know
so that was it you know going into the
night session I don't think there was
any any trades in that night session
doesn't look like this it's kind of a
quiet session yeah yeah I'm sure we'll
get some probably in an hour or so but
that's the crude oil okay euro currency
yesterday is the 1-minute chart as I
forgot to open up a neat range chart but
there's one signal it was a losing trade
right here just stopped you I'm not
gonna say you know support became
support again you know we I don't know I
kind of quarterback it that way but um
draw it out no you know I mean you had
your support level here I would have I'd
be more interested if the buying came
back in here you see we're just sort of
hanging around it but you know if
anything I look you get the sell-off
come back up in here I honestly the way
I would have traded this is that ahead
I'd have limits in here cells not buys
you know I'd be getting short here what
stops right above here to get out right
because what I'd be looking for is this
market to the support level breakdown
rally back up in here get short and sell
off again you know beginning again I
know people that will also you know they
get short here and buy stops up here if
that fails they'll have you know more
stops to get in here you know because
they're gonna look to catch this move
back up alright but again you know
there's just a lot of different ways to
trade there's no one right way to trade
there's a lot of different ways you know
it's it's part of your trading plan you
got to decide how you're going to trade
but don't the last chart I want to show
you is the the e minis alright so this
is the e-mini one-minute chart
and do you see how you know since the
cash opened cash open here what it was
that 2590 started rallying you got this
nice mind and balance you continue to
rally up up up you get up here towards
this high up in here you hit the high
knee over the next five minutes you keep
hitting it once twice three times and
you got the cell in a balance and then
the market if you remember a market sold
off are you gonna know they're selling
balance in there but again you know this
is where if if you're not trained to
look for things you know in the order
flow if you don't know what to look for
in the order flow what's the point of
using a footprint chart right now it's
kind of pointless you know you could use
whatever you want I mean that's you know
I see these quote trading prop houses
nowadays they like to call themselves
prop houses is I'm not gonna name names
but you know let's say oh you know we
got our Platinum membership you know pay
us five thousand dollars five thousand
pounds and you know we'll teach you how
to be a prop trader when you know what
they do is they just put you to sit you
down in front of a dome or or a chart
and say okay here stare at it and figure
it out yourself basically I'll just give
you a little bit of guidelines that you
could probably just get off the internet
for free anyway but you know there's
specific things that you have to look
for right and you know if you don't know
what to look for you're not gonna find
them and you know that's why I think I
create these tools because you know I've
been staring at this is what I did for
20 years I stared at the screen for
God's sakes and it's freaking boring
honestly but there's certain things I'm
looking for right and so can you see in
here or reasons to be selling just in
the order flow you're looking at a one
minute chart no okay but if if you look
at here you could see it you know this
is what my indicators kicking off right
here right up here at this high you hit
the high you're still trading in a zone
you got five minutes more than five
minutes to get short yeah sure you can
get short here on the stacks on a
balance that's a great sell actually as
well um you know and and what happens if
you look at a minute based chart you
know a lot easier to see this is it this
is that high what do we do 25
ninety-three and a half all the way down
into new lows immediately down into you
know 80
five and a half he eventually went lower
you know I mean what other methods are
gonna give you ways to see what's
happening and get short at the high or
right at the high around the high of the
day you know to catch a move I'm getting
short at the high of the day now again
I'm not trying to predict the highs or
lows I'm letting the market tell me what
it sees and you can see it you know
that's on a 1-minute chart
gosh go from the high down to the low
you know was there anything there was a
sell later in the day did it didn't work
yeah I mean yeah we sold off one into
the cash Cole's sold off but again you
know the move you know that yeah that's
it that's a nice little winning trade
you know your resistance later became
support you draw it out you can see here
we trade back down here but I mean
really they wanted to talk about is this
one here this is a these are the moves
that you want as a trader one trade a
day get this one happy days you know you
get this other one that's a little bit
of a winner this is about a point you
know 2585 down to 25 you know 8300 point
and a half eighty three and a half
that's also a decent trade but that's
nothing compared to this trade now I'm
not saying you'd sell it up here and buy
it down here you can sell it here and if
you cover it down in here you're already
happy you already have five five handles
out of that trade already so I'll learn
it on that again if you're free this
afternoon cause it's afternoon this
morning you know trying to sign up for
my webinar and again you can go to the
description below or go to my website
the the sign up here I'll try and put it
in here this you can sign up on my
website just go to WWE order flows
dot-com slash sign up HTML that's what
it is make it a little smaller so it
fits on there that's what you do you
could sign up there again if you can't
attend can't attend but at least if
you're signed up you can catch the be
emailed the link to the replays when
they're available usually the next day
or two so anyway thanks again and he
said if you're interested in the in
cater it is available it's available for
NinjaTrader seven and ninjatrader eight
both versions are available right now
I'm gonna have a special on my webinar
today to get the software if you already
have one of my other softwares it's I'll
be sending out a an email later today
we're going with a discount if you're
already say you got the Delta scalper
people asking how to use this with the
Delta scalper
it's basically simple all right you know
where support or resistance is based on
this indicator then if you see the Delta
scalper giving you a signal within a few
bars take it and again next week I'm
going to try and do a live I'm hoping to
do a live presentation of this indicator
on the 15th the timing is still yet to
be determined
but you know it's gonna be for users of
the software that have the indicator and
it says I think it's gonna it's gonna
you know not change the way you look at
the markets but it's gonna open up you
know the markets to you know how you can
approach it you know trading is not
being a one-trick pony or having only
one in you know one I'll say one
indicator but having only one way to
trade because you know markets don't
trade in one way sometimes they trade in
a range sometimes they trend and
sometimes you know you're gonna get
reversals so if you could have a way to
trade you know all three of those and
basically you've got you know three
different trading methods you know three
different trading plans you can go into
you can go insane okay well I know if
we're gonna range trade this is how I'm
gonna approach it if you know the
markets going to trend this is how I'm
gonna approach it you know when the
markets gonna make a reversal hopefully
I could catch it you know if I catch
every reversal you're not gonna catch
every trend you're not gonna catch every
range zone but again you know you know
you don't need to right if you could
catch that you know that that move like
I showed you in the ESPYs
you know that's the all tax tax tax tax
tax tax tax decks or I forget that's
what I wanted to talk about today is dax
right okay because the dax is the
markets that moves a lot right and this
is this morning
you know you know what time it is now
but you can see here right this is the
eighth today's you know it's just
Wednesday in a pie signal right here 13
380 trades all the way up to you know
390 you got a sell signal this one
didn't work okay
rally back up okay I'm not gonna say
this support this resistance became
support here we're just sort of training
around it then we broke up then you got
failed signal here a failed signal there
okay fine you know we're only been open
for an hour and a half two hours but and
we'll see what what's gonna let's go how
it's gonna take shape but let's take a
look let's go back to yesterday you know
this is a market right that if you're
right you could be rewarded very quickly
if you're wrong
fine you get out very quickly but you
know let's just take a look here you
know I mean you know going back to
whatever 3:00 in the morning I mean I I
say I'm not sure what time I open my
chart okay so just go back say this one
failed on yeah okay fine you're getting
short here at 3:00 what does that say
you're getting short here you know
worst-case scenarios you know 3:21 5:21
yeah you're stopped out you know call
five up here way up here okay you lost
four tix but you're getting long in here
at 98 99 something in here wants to do
trades all you know you got to be
trailing your stop you know long at 98
you know trades all the way up in here
maybe you're getting stopped out in here
I don't know that's a no five maybe
you're trailing your stop and you're
stopped out up here a little bit higher
I don't know you know this this buy
fails here's it a sell you got a little
bit of a move out of it again you're
telling your stop maybe you getting
something out of it you get it short
here you get stopped out but then here
are you getting short at 500 you know
right here this is 500 here you got one
bar two bars boom from 500 all the way
down to 75 this is 75 right here I mean
the low is 71 and a half but look at
this
very quickly you're rewarded so you know
all these little dings here there boom
forget about it
you know you're short here at 98 so call
it here 98 or 97 so you short at 97
you're out at you know your stops up
here at o2 it's 5 ticks but you just you
know went from 513 500 down to 475
that's 25 ticks so you lost 5 but you
just got back 25 then you sort of
spinning around in here here here you
know here you get stopped out maybe you
get stopped out and this I don't know
you could squeeze something out of this
these two maybe maybe not but again you
got another trade in here you get in
short you'll call it 79 you know trades
ollie back up here but you know if
you're trailing you're stopping 79 maybe
getting out here I'm not say you know
you get out on here now you'd probably
be trying to stop these to fail on you
this one fails you get stopped out most
likely then again you hear you know you
get a short from 57 58 57 58 all the way
down and to you know the low 50 then you
got another move here yourself all by by
really quick this is not a scratch
probably losing a few ticks but then you
catching this by right you're getting
along at you know 63 64 trades all the
way up in here you're getting a sell
signal up here at 70 all right you got a
buy here and you probably not gonna take
another bite already long from here but
then you got a sell signal here 68 go
from 68 all the way down to you know the
50s you know maybe you're trailing
you're stopped you're getting out you
know somewhere over here 58 let's see
I'd love to say you catch this whole
move here you got to buy this one failed
okay fine but you can stopped out
relatively quick it's not like you're
getting you're buying it here and you're
getting stopped off down here know you
know that if you're on the other side of
this it's it's time to bail out of that
trade you know here's one you know it
starts going up maybe maybe you get out
maybe you get stopped out down here on
this bar okay fine you got another entry
right here you're getting long 65 what
do you do you just suddenly got this
don't you know cash is closed at this
time so moves are not as violent but
again you know if you're getting getting
along from you know is this sixty six
sixty five you know all the way up into
the 70
up in here 80s even really late in the
day you got another buy signal here but
again you know this is this is the
beauty of the indicator on different
markets again this is the setting that I
got on here you know I don't know what I
got out here this one's set to fifty
minimum volume threshold of 50 you know
because you know Dax on a one minute
chart you know sometimes it trades
decent volume sometimes a dozen I want
to restrict the indicator to given
signals one you know it's a minimum of
50 contracts trade so you know hopefully
by now you can see you know the power of
this indicator and then hopefully you
can wrap it into your own your own style
of trading so thanks everyone and again
you'll try and catch my webinar later
today if you can if you can't oh well
thanks everyone have a great day